everyone dreams of being a star but
these kids managed to really pull it off
from social media stars to kids with
millions in the bank you won't believe
just how famous some of these children
are now let's check out stars who became
famous before the age of 13 lauren grey
if you've had an app called musical dot
ly now renamed as tick-tock
you probably remember Lauren gray Lauren
was only 12 years old when she made her
musical ly account and she quickly
became one of the most popular muses 24
million followers later Lauren has
become known for her amazing cover songs
she definitely became an internet
sensation to the point where stars such
as Millie Bobby Brown know who she is in
2018 Lauren officially took her musical
ly career to the next level and signed
with Virgin Records yep that's right
she got an actual record deal so you
know we'll be hearing more from her in
the next few years this musical dot ly
queen is also instafamous and it's very
clear that people love her she's
relatable sweet and an incredibly
talented singer Jojo C WA next on our
list is the one and only
Jojo C WA the Internet collectively
freaked out in 2018 when they found out
that Jojo is actually 15 years old but
let's be honest this ball of energy
became famous years ago it all started
on a show called Abby's ultimate dance
competition which eventually landed her
a spot on Dance Moms
and Jojo was barely 10 years old then
Jojo
with the bobo was absolutely slaying
every episode and her wild personality
quickly became a fan fave she then got a
YouTube channel and basically took over
the Nickelodeon world her reported net
worth stands at an impressive 8 million
and this kid just turned 15 inches you
know what that's pretty impressive right
Milly Bobby Brown Milly Bobby Brown is
most known for her role as seven on the
hit show stranger things people have
totally fallen in love with her by the
age of 13 Milly claimed success by
winning a Primetime Emmy Award which is
pretty incredible this talented
youngster signed up for acting classes
just to have something to
she never realized they would help her
become one of the most successful teens
on the planet before stranger things
milli appeared on once upon a time
Modern Family and Grey's Anatomy but her
performance as 11 really blew people
away
speaking of Millie did you know that
she's partially deaf allegedly the
directors have to talk very loudly on
set so Millie can hear them that
definitely doesn't stop Millie from
reaching to the stars Chloe grace Moretz
Chloe started gaining popularity after
her role in the Amityville Horror by the
age of 12
Chloe was featured in Big Momma's House
2 500 days of summer and Desperate
Housewives seriously by the time she was
13 Chloe had an established acting
career most people can only dream of she
even got to train with Jackie Chan's
stunt crew and did most of her own
stunts which is pretty amazing
she was also crowned as the busiest
young actress in Hollywood being exposed
to so many roles taught Chloe to be
outspoken about the mistreatment of
women in Hollywood she's a proud
feminist who doesn't give it into the
Hollywood stereotypes and prefers using
everything
junko girl Mackenzie Foy most people
know Mackenzie from Twilight
she was Edward and Bella's child aka Ren
as me at the age of 4 Mackenzie started
her career as a model and quickly
progressed to acting and since then
she's been keeping pretty busy you can
find her in the conjuring interstellar
and plenty of more movies in 2018 she
also landed a lead role in the
Nutcracker movie alongside Keira
Knightley pretty good for a child
vampire right just kidding
it's clear Mackenzie did extremely well
for herself since her twilight days her
reported net worth stands at an
impressive $1,000,000 and we have a
feeling it will only grow in a few years
we'll definitely see more of this
talented actress Willow Smith who could
possibly forget about Willow Smith who
made us all whip our hair when she was
just 10 years old the song immediately
transported her into the a-list Hall of
Fame where she resides with the rest of
her family but let's be honest Willow
was famous since she was born it's all
thanks to her mom and dad Jada and Will
Smith Willa frequently talks about what
it's like growing up in such a famous
family
and according to her it definitely comes
with plenty of negative points but will
learn to express herself through her
style and her music her net worth
reportedly stands at an impressive four
million dollars and we bet it will only
increase as willow releases more and
more bumps Jaden Smith and if we talk
about Willow Smith we also have to talk
about Jaden Smith Jaden Smith grew to
popularity with the modern rendition of
the Karate Kid movie where he really
showed his acting chops he's basically
Will Smith's mini-me since Karate Kid
Jaden's been pretty busy with his music
career he's also landed a spot on Times
list of most influential teens for the
past couple of years people are
absolutely in love with his expressive
fashion sense and ability to speak his
mind and have really intellectual
conversations honestly if we could have
a conversation with Jaden we definitely
would Jaden's net worth reportedly
stands at 8 million which is a result of
his role in the pursuit of happiness as
wellas Karate Kid as of 2018 he's
continuously releasing music and
exploring more and more at this creative
side what is comfo Dakota Fanning Dakota
Fanning Elle Fanning sister has been in
the Hollywood limelight since she was
little you could see her in movies such
as I am Sam and uptown girls where she
starred next to iconic Brittany Murphy
as a child Dakota was known for her
bubbly and giggly interviews she could
pretty much term anyone around her you
could also see her in Twilight and she
even got a small role in friends pretty
impressive for a teenager right as of
2018 Dakota is 24 years old but she's
been pretty much famous before she
became 10 years old her net worth
reportedly stands at an amazing 16
million dollars in November 2018 her
acting resume showed that we'll be
seeing a lot more from this talented
actress in the next half a year and we
honestly can see her anywhere
Annie Leblanc if you follow a lot of
YouTube vloggers you probably came
across Annie Leblanc her family owns the
popular YouTube channel called grit
Haley
has millions of subscribers the family
uploads every single day and Annie and
her sister Haley are the stars of the
show
Annie became popular after people
started to take notice of her awesome
gymnastic skill but as her YouTube fame
grew she became an actress and she even
had a couple of number-one hits on
iTunes
Annie was born in 2014 which means she
barely turned 14 by 2018 and yes this
kid is pretty much one of the biggest
internet stars ever
do you like Annie when she was doing
gymnastics more or do you prefer seeing
her in LA filming shows come let us know
in the comments Daniela Bhrigu Lea let's
move on to one of the most controversial
teens that started off as a meme and
eventually progressed to an actual music
career no one expected the cash may
outside girl to maintain her popularity
over the years Danielle was barely 13
when the internet turned her into an
instant sensation since her appearance
on dr. Phil Danielle managed to make a
name for herself in just a couple of
years she's been releasing music that
makes a lot of people bought their heads
and dance too so it's safe to say she's
doing something right of course she's
still pretty much a wild child but this
kid seems to be doing a lot better than
she was during her dr. Phil days and
let's be honest we can't wait to hear
more of her music
grace Vander Waal grace was 12 years old
when she graced us with her presence on
America's Got Talent
and her talent definitely made the
entire America listen because grace
became an instant sensation she won the
show and her sound is extremely unique
which is why so many people are
interested in her music race is
extremely bubbly playful and incredibly
talented she kept her singing talent to
herself and her friends didn't even know
about it until that iconic golden buzzer
audition played before their eyes this
little cutie is super busy but she still
tries to be a normal kid her net worth
reportedly stands at 2 million dollars
which is absolutely amazing for someone
who taught herself how to play the
ukulele and one egt because of it
Lindsay Lohan but let's take it back to
some old-school kid actors you probably
forgot about if you were born in the 90s
the next few names are definitely for
you Lindsay Lohan was a child actress
that became an in
start with the release of the popular
Parent Trap movie honestly she did an
amazing job playing herself and her twin
sister and she was just 11 years old a
couple of years later Lindsay released
her first album and had plenty of war
movie roles but the one that were really
put her on the map was without a doubt
Mean Girls unfortunately it looks like
Lindsay is no longer interested in a
full-time acting career but we have a
feeling everyone still knows at least
one quote from Mean Girls it's like how
could you know it was I believe the
iconic mary-kate and Ashley Olsen but if
we talk about Lindsay Lohan we also have
to talk about these two mary-kate and
Ashley Olsen brewed to popularity as
toddlers on the hit show full house
where they both played Michelle Tanner
the role enabled them to pretty much
build their own empire from TV shows to
movies the Olsen twins became a huge
name in Hollywood New York minute was
one of the last movies the girls have
filmed before leaving Hollywood to build
their fashion empire they didn't even
return for the full house reboot despite
the fact that every original cast member
came back to the show these days the
twins live a much quieter life
completely dedicated to the world of
fashion but you have to admit that the
Olsen twins were once one of the most
popular toddlers around Maddie Ziegler
if we mentioned Jojo C WA you know we
have to talk about one of the most
influential teens on the planet ever
since starring in Dance Moms Maddie
Ziegler has been recognized as one of
the most talented young dancers ever
even see a thought so which is why she
invited her to perform in her new iconic
chandelier music video the video
skyrocketed Maddie to fame and she
became a well-known face in the dance
world as well as Hollywood nowadays
Maddie is pretty busy dancing but she
has also been a judge on So You Think
You Can Dance she toured with SIA she's
had a couple of movie roles and she's
overall living her best life her
reported net worth is about five million
dollars which is pretty awesome we love
Maddie and we can't wait to see more of
her dancing Miley Cyrus and last but not
least Miley Cyrus was one of the most
popular child
she was just 11 years old when Hannah
Montana first started but guess what
she didn't even audition for Hannah at
first she auditioned for Lilly how crazy
is that she got the Hannah rule because
of her amazing singing skills and it's
safe to say that the rest is history
Miley went on to have a successful music
career as well as plenty of
controversies most kid actors have but
nowadays she's back and she's still
using her beautiful voice to make
gorgeous songs although her family did
admit that Hannah Montana changed their
lives in not the most positive way it's
safe to say it turned Miley into an
ultimate triple threat superstar from
acting singing to modeling there's
nothing this girl can't do what do you
think who's the biggest child star on
our list who's your favorite who do you
hate come tell us everything in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time